Good morning, John.
Today I want to delve into a peculiar practice of that most mysterious of cultures,
the American.
It's a deeply illogical practice,
economically troubling,
psychologically dubious-
I will regularly give money to people who are not asking for it.
I'm not required by law to do this
but I feel as if I should.
And I don't know why I feel this way;
I've recently discovered that I don't know why I feel a lot of the ways that I feel.
I'm kind of an insane person.
For example, I spend many of my afternoons watching videos about goat sex and fictional soccer teams.
But anyway,
to start off our discussion about tipping, I want to go into my personal rules
which are,
as it happens,
the best rules for how to tip.
If you are in a restaurant that has a JAR,
a dollar goes in the jar,
if I have a dollar.
If I don't have a single,
then you're screwed.
You sit down and someone comes to you to bring you food and talk to you
then that person deserves, at the very minimum,
fifteen percent.
But almost never do they get 15%,
because there are three ways that they can increase their tip.
ONE.
Good service.
TWO.
If I feel particularly nice that day.
THREE.
The math is difficult
and so I round up.
My personal inability to do math in my head
is probably responsible for my most generous tips.
If at the end of step two,
I have not gotten above two dollars per person,
I give two dollars per person,
Leaving a 25% tip
on a three dollar bill
is not good tipping.
Now, next thing,
after a deep psychological investigation of my own inner self,
I have figured out
that what I would like to be the reason for me giving tips
is that those people are making me happy so I want to make them happy.
But,
there are a lot of lesser motives that I believe are, in fact,
much more responsible.
Waitstaff make less than 50% of their living off of their wages,
most of their living is from tips and so I would feel bad.
Also, I live in a very small town
and the person who's waiting on me is probably friends with someone who I'm friends with
and I don't want it getting around that I'm a jerk face.
And I think the number one reason why I do it
is because it's the thing to do.
The more I think about it, the more I realize that pretty much everything I do,
I do because it's the thing to do
and I don't know why the thing to do is the thing to do,
it just is.
Sometimes, I feel like my entire life is just one long string of
"That's the thing to do."
Get out "thing to do"!
I don't need you!
I make my own things to-
I don't!
My brain
is encapsulated by this culture,
and it makes me do all the "things to do".
Not that I mind,
I mean, most of "things to do" are pretty cool.
Now, the reason why tipping is supposed to be the thing to do,
is because we want to encourage
good service.
It is important to note
that this does not work.
Things that influence tip more than the quality of service include:
the ethnicity of the waiter or waitress,
the gender of the waiter or waitress,
the weather outside on that particular day,
the cost of the meal
and whether or not they've drawn a smiley face on the check.
Smiley face,
interestingly,
raises the tip of waitresses by 9%,
lowers the tip of waiters by 3%.
W T F.
Here's the thing about tipping,
96% of Americans do it every single time,
but in lots of other countries, that's just not a thing that could st-
In fact, in like Japan and China
it's considered an insult.
In Europe, where there are service charges included in the check,
higher wages
and also
like medical care
that's inexpensive or free,
waiters and waitresses don't need tips in order to be above the poverty line.
In the United States, however,
we have this idea that everything should be
controlled by the market,
which is how the UK ends up with television shows like
QI and Doctor Who
and we are stuck with documentaries about
fictional apocalypses
on the History Channel.
And that
is why tipping kills Time Lords.
I don't- where- how did I get here?
Leave the most interesting comment to win
my winnie-the-pooh-sters.
John, I will see you on Monday,
when you celebrate
our FIFTH anniversary.
It's a wonderful life.
Don't forget to be awesome and if you're in America,
don't forget to tip at least $2 per seat.